okay we're just gonna go through
something on the nem focus website that
some people know about but it's also a
good introduction to all of the nem
focused projects so you're on numb focus
org projects we there's sponsored and
affiliated if we have time we'll look at
affiliated we're gonna go to sponsored
projects what's the difference between
sponsored and affiliated project and
then focused you ask a sponsored project
our projects that numb focus has signed
a fiscal sponsorship agreement which is
a legal agreement and numb focus is
serving as a legal entity for that
project we sign for them on legal
documents we take on all liability so it
is the individual developers do not have
liability again handling their legal
administration of all their finances and
many other things but what this is this
is a great tool that has all our
projects on it and you can go through
and you can look at language or features
and we'll just pull up if we want to see
what's Python and well let's see we'll
pick another one Python and JavaScript
and you look and it will pull those up
so you can do that with any of any of
the projects or languages it's kind of a
handy tool because many people ask you
know what language can this project work
with so that is one thing the other one
is features if you wanted to see all the
modeling tools then it shows all the
modeling tools and so you have those
pulled up and you're wondering which we
get I've heard this question asked three
times today what this sticker is
right here so that's Cantera so you want
to learn more about Cantera you can
click on Cantera
and we find out that it's an open-source
software suite that helps solve problems
involving thermodynamics chemical
reaction rates and fluid transport
processes and you could go down further
a description technical details as well
as applications for the project
that's just drilling down a little bit
deeper applications lets you know that
the largest user base of canterra is in
the combustion field but it can be used
in other atmospheric and in astronomical
chemistry so go back to project so that
is features will uncheck modeling and
you can also do run a search based on
industry whether it's business higher
education you know it's used in academia
our government will click on government
really quick
see what comes up so it's showing that
these 12 tools are used in government I
think that's somewhat incorrect because
I know many other ones that are that are
also a couple other ones that I know for
a fact are use that aren't on here maybe
just one or two but that covers that's
most of them and again I'm trying to
think of another oh I know another
project that someone when I was at the
table with the stickers asked what it
was
that's interact so again we find out
that now we're going we which clicked on
the interact page
back here it's a standalone desktop
application for developing computational
notebooks and again it's you can look at
its applications that it's being used
extensively at Netflix and also being
used by plotly so hopefully you find
that helpful the other thing that's kind
of nifty here is that there's a button
for to contribute code so for all our
projects have a page you click on that
it will tell you about contributing code
to that project it doesn't go into
doesn't you know it's not a contributor
workshop but it does tell you
information on how to contribute code
and that's on there for each of our
projects as well as a easy link to the
website and how to donate specifically
to that project because donations can be
made to non focus for all the projects
so those donations all the projects or
you can donate to a project specifically
so this will take you to the specific
project page so and again just super
quickly I won't go into any details but
the affiliated project if you want
information on our affiliated projects
these projects are able to apply for an
unfocused small development grants and
they're included in many of our
announcements and just informational
resources that we send out to projects
you can take a look at all the
affiliated projects and find out all
about them on this page Thanks
hi everyone so I just want to talk
briefly about model explain ability and
in particular the library we've
developed that Seldon where I work at so
the libraries called alibi and it
enables you to explain blackbox model
predictions so model explain ability is
a huge topic so I could talk for hours I
don't have hours so let's jump into some
examples so for example I've trained
I've have data set income classification
this is a standard data set it's got
about 13 features age working class of
the individuals and it's a binary
classification problem whether the
individual makes more than or less than
50k a year so I've split the data I've
trained an off-the-shelf classifier by
the way all these examples are available
as a documentation on our website so I
don't worry if you can't follow all of
it but I have a trained classifier it
has some performance but now I want to
explain specific predictions so I'm
gonna use an anchor for explainer which
will find the the most important
features for that particular instance
from the point of view of the model to
make a positive or negative prediction
so I initialize explain fit it on the
training data I'll try and get one
instance I've got an instance an
individual for whom the model predicts
that they're a low earner okay but why
so then we can run the explainer and
we'll see okay
the model thinks that because the
marital status is never married it will
always predict a low income because of
that and you see there's some there's
some there's some metadata there it
gives you it gives you guarantees how
where this explanation implies so 92
percent precision so this exploit
explanation will be valid roughly 92
percent of the time so if you if you
look into interpretability line is a
technique that was developed maybe four
years ago and anchors are from the same
authors and it's kind of like an
improvement in my more robust gives you
more guarantees it's not limited to have
your data sets you can do any images so
let's say
fashion m-miss data set 10 categories
I've trained to see an end-of-line do
some predictions
I've segmented the image into super
pixels so that computation of anchors is
quicker and also more interpretable and
then again anchors are completely black
box method so all you need is a predict
function this could be anything it can
be it can be a naked API running in
production so if you want you can wrap
up your explain it with the flask server
and run as a micro service in production
which we have examples of in installed
and core anyway back to the explanations
let's see that's a pullover with 99%
confidence by the model what's the
explanation let's do the anchor okay
that's the anchor so as long as there's
like this right left sleeve the model
thinks it's always a pullover nothing
else so it's a simple data set so that's
what it gets in blanket runs or more
complex data sets imagenet it's a
Persian cat why is it a Persian cat
world because of this
okay another interesting technique is
counterfactuals which ask the opposite
question what do I need to change for my
model sorry for my instance to get the
opposite prediction of the model so
there's an example with the Boston
housing data set again classification
problem is the is the is in any given
house more or less valuable than the
median value in the neighborhood and
we've trained some model now we can
create a counterfactual instance of a
house given that a house was classified
as low value what do we need to change
to classify as high value and if I run
this example it actually says ok
actually I need to sort of CL start
decrease the percentage of the lowest
status of population in the area to get
a positive prediction so so you can't
this is not actionable right so you
can't change that but with counts
fractures you can restrict your
attention to which features are
actionable so you can find
counterfactual instances and then act on
them so that could be useful yeah so we
have a few of the techniques oh yeah
what count factors also work on images
this is a seven you want to see what you
want to change to get not seven and you
get four that was a different example
anyway thank you
cool good to see everyone here so I'm
just gonna quickly go through these
slides quite new to Python so let me
know if you guys have any feedback in
terms of making code better and stuff
but essentially the idea here is that
the UK crime police forces sorry the UK
police forces they produce crime data
and they put it up so that people can
download it do whatever they want with
it so I'm gonna go through that and
essentially how I visualized it using
matplotlib and plotly so so we can go
through that as well cool so what's the
motivation well for so it was me and my
partner actually did this very quick
thing but we're kind of looking to rent
slash buy a house so you know we want to
find places which have slightly lower
crime or we want to find streets
specifically which have low or high
crime and you know kind of make make a
decision from there so there are crime
maps available and but the problem is is
that most of the times they're very hard
to work with so it's either they just
give you data for one month or for one
region and then you have to kind of
click through and go through each month
to find out like you know the data so
the idea here is to try and get all of
that data and be able to visualize that
at the same time and the data is really
good it's really good that they've put
it there
I'm sure there's much more interesting
things that people can do but this is
just a start and yeah so so that's
that's the idea so I'm just going to go
through like this to note that we've
made and it's so it's on github so
github name is joy - Rosie and its UK
crime police later and yeah you can you
can find the notebook where so we do all
the imports we use pandas geo pandas
matplotlib and plotly those are like the
four main things that we're using and
I'm using this thing called map box so
mat box is it's basically an API that is
actually embedded within plotly so you
can kind of use their street-level Maps
and other maps to try and basically
visualize these things so user
parameters you know wherever you store
the data which I have a script for as
well for downloading data it's not in
here
what's the region what kind of data type
it is and what this starting the end
dates so this is what the raw data looks
like you know there's some crime ID
there's month reported by so this is the
police service longitude latitude of the
streets location some codes and the
crime type so then what we do is we
clean the date so we make a look a bit
nicer we we only want certain things at
least in this specific case we want the
longitude latitude and the crime type
and the date so then we use geo pandas
which is awesome if anyone's if you guys
aren't use it do check it out so it's
basically like you can work with
geometry's and do cool things like
spatial as it joins so if you have a
point and you can do a join on a polygon
and then you know you can put them
together so like it's an equivalent of
doing left joins the stuff from SQL and
so I'm just I'm just getting what's
called the CRS so that's a coordinate
reference system so essentially here
what I'm trying to do is I'm just trying
to get out the data for London not the
whole of UK because that's why I'm
interested in specifically so what I can
do is if long as I know the longitude
latitude Bandar YZ or London I can
spatial join all of my data onto there
to only get the London data so imagine
you have the whole of the UK data but
you only won the London later how do you
do it what you can use do around is to
do this join and just get out what you
want in the end and so and this is just
there's there's some unnecessary stuff
dealing with coordinate systems but it's
it's done here and then so first thing
that we do visualize in MATLAB very
simple we just have the we just have the
pandas object or the G openers object in
this case we just do dot plot blah blah
blah blah blah and you get the pot so
you can see the blue is just the London
area and then the red is each crime in
London and this is this is for five
years say we make and then and then what
we do is we then use plot Lee so I
advocate all the data by Street by the
data tire by the crime type so that's
like antisocial behavior
you know shoplifting robberies on and so
forth and this is what it looks like so
I was I was really impressed with the
plotly and the matte box stuff so this
is quite interactive so I'm try to make
it somewhat like a a heat map and you
can zoom in so I think we are so we're
in this area somewhere around here and
we can have a look okay well there's
been about two hundred crimes in the
past five years and you know but it
doesn't seem that a lot of them my
antisocial behavior so like you know
it's just
hopefully children walk around doing
lots of thing but that's it hello
everyone so I'm ELISA and I'm here with
Cambridge spark the screen up here may
might may have given you a clue as to
what I'm here to speak about so how is
everyone enjoying the PI data conference
so far fantastic that's what I like to
hear because I'm here to talk about PI
data Cambridge which of course yeah
you're all excited about already
fantastic yeah so I just wanted to take
a couple minutes of your time to let you
know that we are organizing PI data
Cambridge on the 15th to the 17th of
November this year and we do have a
stand just here by the t-shirts so if
you'd like some more information about
that event just come across and talk to
us or just come and grab a little
postcard just to remind yourself when
it's happening so you don't forget to
buy your tickets or you know sponsor the
event or you know have a talk yeah
whatever it is that you're interested in
yeah
I'm gonna keep it short and sweet you
know where to find me so yeah enjoy the
rest of the conference
thank you yeah I don't come with these
lights this time I come with my twitter
handler that can be very useful after
the bad jokes when you want to block me
so I'm going to show you or something
I've been working on recently it
a new pandas Peter let me just show your
first disease pandas as a disclaimer
step unders of the filter 0.25 is still
not release it in release candidate so
let me just open ops sorry easier to to
write when when not so many people is
looking at your yeah I have I got a data
data set with all the PI data meetups
okay we actually got more columns but I
just cared about this tool so I think
you probably all know about this I'm
going to check just like past events dot
plot sorry I'm going to just plot just
the largest ones let's see how these how
this looks like
they're called the largest PI data the
large data that organize more events is
Pilate London together with PI data
Berlin I think some organizers did a lot
of work then we have things like pi
theta New York organize as many as a
small island in in Spain I don't know
where it James but maybe wants to tell
us how long our siesta so what that was
all on our sisters in in New York I'm
going to go to member accounts and we
can't okay we got the by far the largest
is PI data London went to do another
plot oops
actually not great with time but let's
see so I want to plot again the member
account is it big enough
are you seeing anything okay I'm going
to plot also the past event so I'm going
to plot inverse things I think that
should be good enough okay and it looks
like in this scatter plot we have
something looks like an order liar and
of course most of us here are or at
least many of us are data scientist we
know that we want to get rid of outliers
but we don't know which is the PI data
we want to get rid of so I would say
that in general they what you would do
is probably check these axes say okay do
a filter and isolate these stuff what
its new in the new version of pandas is
let me go somewhere here I'm going to
say this is HV plot ok and what I'm
getting now is interactive plots
okay now we can see exactly how many
members has Pilate a London well that
was yesterday when I generated this data
frame now we can we can also detect this
or layer yeah this is the Pareto we need
to get rid of sorry Marco and Ian and
the rest of organizers and I don't know
I thought you wouldn't be impressed so I
implemented my own plotting back in how
pandas can will support any plotting
will support altair or lordly or any
backing that is implemented it would be
third-party libraries I implemented one
that it was awesome that I had to rename
it after the first version ok what it
does is it plots with emojis okay it's
actually a bit sad but still a bit too
realistic because as you see all the all
the faces are men I didn't like that so
what I did was you have an option that
you can in lemon and say okay they are
all it's kind of cool is not really
diverse I thought it was I can I can
even be cooler so everybody a panda yeah
in terms of diversity this is not being
great because I don't have actually time
let me just go quickly to the future and
see what this library is able to tell
about all these pie eaters in the future
okay it's making it as diverse as as we
want the community so because I just got
five second left to show my skater okay
I didn't have a skater for that thank
you
oh yeah I want to show you this thing
now the in this video it's like showing
an and it's showing an error message
because yeah why not this thing is
called pew pew I wish I got this as a
gift if you can see it's a gift from
your Python it's super cool because I
know that most of us are data scientists
so we use Python to work with data but
not a lot of us was able to use Python
for something that is more fun so yeah
so I'm like I'm looking at like all
these crazy thing that people created
like for example this one is it's the
game 2048 who had to play that game on
your phone before yes so somebody
program it on this thing so but this is
just animation I can't really show you
but this one I can show you the thing
like somebody programmed a flappy bird
with this also somebody programmed a
clock this way like it is where it's
gonna take more than five minutes a
thinkers like yeah this gotta move but
it's analog clock but you have to tilt
your head yeah so I would like to show
you my creation because like of course
my creation is now you see me hi okay um
so yeah this thing so my creation is not
as creative as those it's just a heart
which did go small and big and go slowly
or fast and it could also stop and start
you can be like yeah change change it so
so yeah this thing is okay I feel weird
looking at myself so let me close it so
basically this thing is it's run on a
circuit python so it's like a
lightweight version of Python and also
these if you lucky as me go to you have
been to Europe - you get one of these
and then there's some code inside that
is provide an API that you could you
could write a program for easily so
that's why I within an hour or so I can
already write this like hot thingy so
yeah
if you want to buy one I don't know of
course you can't get this one because
you can get a Europe - well now but like
if you look online there's actually this
is copy of you and also there's another
thing similar core PI patch that yeah so
you can have fun and I think yeah I just
think that we should use Python for
other fun stuff not just of course like
you can have fun with data but also you
can do maybe you can have this one and
also do some machine learning with it I
think somebody said it it could be done
so yeah why not thank you my name is
Michael and this short we'll talk will
explain what are get hooks so what will
you get from this is that you will know
what's a get hook and why you should
them in Python development and how easy
is this really to use them so eight
months ago I had a meeting daily stand
up with our friends from my current
contract and we had a discussion about
using single quotes and double quotes
right it's a great discussion so and
someone found black and we decided okay
you don't discuss with a script so that
was a very good idea and we decided okay
we will use them use it right the black
and so how should we use it and someone
proposed that maybe you can use it in
your code editor you know formats and
every safe right but not everyone was
using vs code so someone got an idea to
use get hooks and we didn't talk about
it for the next six months right so get
hooks like this a script and basically
they execute before or before after even
such a comet push and receive Inc it so
you have those scripts in the dot get
hooks direct trick
and they are really a script so on the
plus side it can be anything Python Perl
bash Haskell right they can do
anything's and emails whatever but you
have to write them or stackoverflow them
and they aren't kept in your repository
right so and basically at that point I
thought that there must be a little way
and I was working late it was pretty
late and I committed my code pushed it
and waited ten minutes for the runner to
be free on our CI and it failed on
anything that was a huge bummer so I
thought what should I do to not have
this issue anymore like to not have to
wait next minute so I thought okay so
you have to live before you commit right
but it's a manual work and I already
failed to do that right minutes lost so
I thought that okay so maybe six months
ago someone who said you know let's use
git hooks right so okay I took my
courage all of it and imagine what I did
I googled it alright so I found a
website called pre-commit dot-com so
easy and basically it's a small
framework for managing and maintaining
multi-language pre-commit hooks you just
do pip install pre-commit and you create
a sample configuration like here just
one file that you need to commit to your
git repository this is the simple thing
right that it removes straining white
spaces removes unnecessary new lines at
the end of file checks ya know files
checks if we aren't committing files
that are too big to the repository right
so you do pre-commit install it will
install in the dot kids slash hooks
directory
and you can run it with pre-commit to
run - a so it will run on all of your
files or it will just leave it for the
comets and it will run before every
comet
so as you can see the fixed end of files
failed and fixed my file at the same
time so I just need to do another comet
and it's done so in our Python
development with my team we use PI llama
for linting we use I sort for sorting
imports so they look nice and we use
black and we don't discuss about
formatting anymore
thank you you can find this on my github
this presentation if you like to have
our configuration thank you
hi everybody my name is Matt metals and
I'm gonna show something about des
boarding with Jupiter notebooks which is
foie and I buy widgets so all this
material can be found at this repo so
this is a project that I'm doing
together with Quan stack but it's it's
fully open source so let's start with a
notebook so I work on BQ plots of
visualization libraries so of course
it's my favorite library let's do some
histogram of some fake data and because
it's big Q plot is built on top of I PI
widgets I can change something
interactively the number of bins but I
want to create some kind of dashboard so
I'm gonna create a slider and link that
to it great now I'm gonna create an
extra plot which is a line chart and I
want to do a selection to filter like
the data that is shown on top so now is
it small yes yeah so now I want to share
that with someone and not show the code
because maybe this person is not
technical or you don't want to show the
code because it's
secret code so there's two ways to do
this well there's a package called a
voila so let me push the button so
there's a button in classical tips in
Outlook or Jupiter lab I need to zoom
out a bit and it will basically render
your jupiter notebook without the code
input but it's still connected to a
kernel so i can do all of this it's also
a command line you tale so let me show
that so you can do voilá like jupiter
notebook and then a notebook you do
voila and then a notebook and now it
will spin up a server that doesn't
include the jupiter notebook so this is
completely safe nobody can change your
notebook nobody can see your notebook
but you are still connected to the
kernel okay so we want to make this a
bit more pretty and one library that we
built on top of iPad which it's called
beautify and what it is it's using
modern web technology a modern web
framework that a library called beautify
that implements the Google's material
design spec giving you these nice
buttons that if you click on them you
get like animations so they've done all
of this work and we wrapped them to get
them in the notebook so things like
spinach let's see let's do
drop-down menus etc and I think the most
pretty one is this where you have a like
a really modern looking app almost that
you can like configure what it looks
like and this in combination with a
template and I can't show you the
template but it's basically it looks
like HTML so you specify what the
template name is so we made a template
that's already like pretty good and we
modified the original notebook a bit and
now everything is nicely laid out so we
have we can change the bin size here we
can change the line style and this is a
notebook running so does this looks like
pretty modern it is actually also
responsive so if I change the size it
should change the placement of where the
charts are and should collapse the
navigation yeah and now it's like a
navigation drawer like this so it
actually works on your mobile phone on
your iPad and so this is running on this
computer
if you want to share that with someone
you can go to this repo matam little
slash voila demo if you click this
binder link it will spin up a binder and
basically show you the same thing but
anyone like if you can click on this
from your phone and if I had enough time
to wait for binder I could show you that
it works another way which is what my
tender node it is to deploy this on
Heroku so basically all the steps to to
do something like this let's see so it's
actually running so this is somewhere on
the cloud just works thank you
yeah I want to introduce your sci-fi to
you your surprise is the scientific
private conference we are the euro
supply this year will be in the
beautiful city of Bilbao which is known
the basque country is known for the
highest density of star restaurants
which are very affordable as well there
it's a beautiful city is well-connected
there were two Europe hyphens back then
which we're also pretty amazing there
and so let me pitch it a little bit more
on the food there's pinches cider house
social events for networking yeah
actually the credit for this slide goes
to mark yeah no but it's it's it's
really great it's a super cool city we
also have the first keynote a notes and
do you see this like tons of great
speakers like Martin Prado so you can
tell you much more about voila and but
we really want to push your side by to
be the conference for arm of course
scientific pythons but also maintenance
for scientific packages so there's a
maintenance track this year as well and
we this is what we're going to build for
the future as well and there's some you
see there's also some great libraries
who are already part of this call for
sponsors is still open
aand so you can just reach out if you
want to sponsor and support this project
you can find more info of course on our
website your Syfy org it's I think the
18 so your sci-fi has been around for a
while and if you want to get more info
is this and short break
because next I have another conference
oh so it's PI Quan de Picardie is the
German Python conference so it has
happened in all these cities all around
Germany ah so that's the 8th edition so
it has happened eight times already and
last year we had a problem where to move
to conference last year we were down in
carceral southern Germany so last year
we we had a real challenge
where should we move the conference
so finally oh no this is too full
animation I didn't plan for that okay
but actually we decided let's go to
Berlin and nice thing happened we got in
touch with Pilate of the line' so we
reached out to each other and actually
we decided let's bring these two
conferences together so we have a joint
conference between PyCon de which is
more like - programming an API whatever
DevOps oriented and PI de belen we it's
it's going to happen in October at
cosmos Berlin cosmos Berlin looks like
this it's part of eastern Germany it's a
nice nice venue here and let me tell you
a little bit more what we have
accomplished so far because actually
it's far thrilling every received tons
of good feedback bringing the
communities together again because it's
always nice to go into like niches and
sub communities but many data scientists
told me all great I can catch up on my
Python and programming skills as well
and then I think it's a it's a really
nice message and so far really the
collaboration has been like pretty good
so I can prove that with some figures so
the CFP unfortunately it's closed
already but we fully received like 450
proposals which is like layers hang yeah
oh my god
so schedule will be up in three weeks we
have a hundred 120 sessions there so
there's seven tracks - tutorial 5 talks
tracks we also include when included a
community in the process so we put up a
community voting on all the submissions
we received we had more than 33,000
votes on that all major sponsor packages
are sold already
so we keep a waiting list for next year
if you are interested we still have
diversity packages so if you want to
give you a company as some presents
please consider diversity packages we
offer free childcare and 2/3 of the
tickets are actually already sold and we
have sold 88 days to the conference so
this has been quite amazing so this for
Berlin
really quick mentioned if you're in
southern Germany you can also go to pi
data's address which is a meet-up
if you don't know where we are let me
pilatus addressed this Mannheim pyro and
this area so so if you come by for
turbos who just ping me if you want to
give a talk or just visit it's great and
of course there's also Pilate of
Frankfurt which is you know already this
was all a last one of our recent pilot
of Frankfurt events and that's it so
thank you very much so yeah so this
talks go well first it was called things
you didn't know about fighting but then
I found out many things are already
known quite well actually but at least
these are things that I did not know
about fighting first a disclaimer I
borrowed many of those examples from a
github repo it's called what the eff
Python so go there apart from the fact
that there's many like surprising things
in Python it's really peculiar it really
helps you at least it helped me to
understand some of their like the
internals of fighting so so apart from
the fact that it's super funny some of
these things really helps you to get a
better understanding of Python in
general so let's get going before making
this talk I did not even know you can
make slides in Jupiter notebook and it's
super super simple and super easy so do
it
Python was conceived in Amsterdam a few
kilometers from the company ever for God
that's driven so it was like a hobby
project of hito frozen in 1989 he says
like my office would be closed but I had
a home computer and not much else on my
hands so it was quite a good way to
spend your Christmas holiday I think and
the rest is history the language name is
a tribute to Monty Python I expect many
people that are from at least UK that I
know this because we wanted bite in it
like a British comedy show but this one
I really didn't know spam and eggs
that's used in like the Python
documentation it comes from a very
famous Python sketch
multiply the sketch I have to say spam
is in general also origins from the
sketch and the sketch is about customers
that try to order breakfast from a menu
that includes spam in almost every dish
much to the consternation of one of the
customers yeah we don't have time to
watch it check it out on YouTube so some
more technical stuff the implementation
of the or statement can you even read
this
yeah was it too small maybe right mmm
yes it is can i zoom in or wait
yeah what's okay so it just says
basically if you say like a or B then it
says if a and otherwise if true you
return a and otherwise return B so Wow
yes so instead if you give like known as
a default argument instead of checking
if X is X is known and otherwise
assigning immutable you can also do this
was quite a surprise to me I don't know
if it's good practice maybe there's
someone around that can tell me it is or
it is not I think it's less explicit but
at least it's interesting to at least
know how this or statement words Python
is for else statement I did not know so
it basically also only hits the else
statements if you iterate through the
full I traitor of the for loop basically
yeah that's one example that you can use
it in some like search thing but I never
used it probably never will nobody ever
got fired for choosing Python it's also
a good one if you say like import this
it returns the same of Python I think
many people know this it's like well
beautiful is better than ugly and a
whole shebang this one is quite peculiar
so if you sign 256 to a and B then
they're like they they're going to the
same like let's say memory slot but
there is not for 257 this is strange
well it turns out all entities between
-5 and 256 are pre initialized in
reference when used so this is I think
for performance things you are doing the
time right because otherwise I go on for
like half an hour it's not as a single
binary operator so it's not that you
have each and mode and you can combine
them but it's not as a single binary
operator Python is to try except else
finally statement also never uses
probably also never will but it has
applications this one is very nice so by
to use indention instead of braces to
stretch these programs in these scripts
into blocks so we all know that but if
you really want
races you can't use braces Abby's just a
dog it doesn't work okay
using mute using mutable object yeah man
if you ever think like what using
mutable object as a function default is
a bad idea and so this is some people I
think I made this mistake in the
beginning without even realizing and
this is like so never use for example a
list as a default argument so you have
to say like X is known and then if known
as for example posting you you assign an
empty list to it in a for loop in every
iteration the item provided by the I
traitor is assigned to target rival so
if you have some of you very i trait
over some string and this is actually
very strange but this is just as a as in
like as an illustration and you you can
like in this for loop you can actually
assign to this dictionary so it's
actually assigned when you loop over it
in quite them you can chain comparisons
so you can if you have like a smaller
than B and be smaller than C you can do
it like this you can also do this I
found it very surprising so you can also
change like equality you let say operate
so here you I would say like okay X is 5
designed to XO first you it's like it's
the me it would say like okay true is
larger than 4 but this is not the case
it's actually changed as one like
operation in fighting to true and false
were built-in variables and not
constants okay this okay
it goes on until like 50 yourself
okay hello so today we had a wonderful
couple hours of very very intense
hacking and I'm going to just give a few
minutes saying what we actually did
together in so we ran a democracy
hackathon and just keep things simple we
had a number of challenges a huge number
of challenges such as let's solve
democracy how do we do that well lots of
the data there which you need to
research into the world of politics and
or the world of sort of candidate
elections and and voting is in PDFs and
this is our greatest data source and it
almost never gets analyzed because it
need to be manually extracted so if
anybody anybody and we did this last
year and if anybody could do that that
would be great it would be a real real
game-changer in this industry voter
engagement fake news misinformation
public sentiment we had a
machine-learning competition because who
doesn't love a machine-learning
competition and we also had a prize
category for open data for democracy
initiatives so number one what do we
managed to do this was what we were
trying to attack all last year and
literally nothing has changed any years
time in this entire space of there is
data there is really good data in PDFs
but it will stay there forever more
until we figure out a better way of
getting out and the state-of-the-art is
still this it's not really good enough
for automated extraction yet this time
we switch things up when you looked at
election candidate data and we realized
there's no standards around any of this
it is just put in there by humans for
human consumption and it reduces very
quickly down to an incredibly almost
intractable NLP problem so that was a
couple a couple people spent a good two
and a half hours on this today and
that's roughly what they concluded some
other people looked at voter engagement
again they were looking at building
tools for making it easier to actually
register to vote because at the moment
it's a very almost manual process of
sending things off so how can we
digitize that entire thing the hardest
bit is actually just the signature
getting that through to your local
office getting that verified so some
really exciting initiatives built by
another team on this front number three
fake news one of the biggest new phrases
of the last
and a few people were looking into how
language was used online especially on
Twitter this turned out to be well it's
never easy to actually get lots of data
off Twitter to start doing some NLP
analysis I think one team was literally
trying to build a very very meaningful
and powerful start by doing some sort of
topological classification of Twitter
graphs again not the easiest thing to do
in a couple hours but they did something
they proved perhaps that tweets
associated with the leave supporters
have a greater strength of opinion take
about what you will number for the
machine learning competition so the
challenge that we posed people this year
was can you predict turnout in election
because it's very hard to actually ask
people to change their opinions on what
they believe it's much easier to just
get them to persuade them that their
vote is worth actually going 300 meters
down to a polling station it's going to
be worth it so if we can figure out how
to predict turnout we can figure out
what the factors are the impact turnout
and so we got our contestants started
with a notebook ready to go and a model
ready to go which had a 4 percent
average error per party per seat and a
team after two and a half hours managed
to reduce that average error from 4
percent down to 0.02 Sampson I believe
with a like GBM model with some census
demographic data merged in and some very
youthful sort of domain knowledge in
fact their quote was we realized that
domain knowledge gave us the most impact
versus just fancier models so
congratulations to that team and their
new winnings of House of Commons branded
coffee for coming on say thank you to
all of them we have more though
and we also had a task around open data
for democracy and this was one of the
hardest things that I've ever incur and
can't come across is just the amount of
time it takes to get the data from its
various data sets and data sources or
even getting it off archive pages that
some other extremely nice person has put
up because the Electoral Commission does
take data set sources down so how do we
get this data how do we make it
accessible how do we make it publicly
available for people like us to just
come and use so it's even possible for
teams to come and solve that machine
learning competition in just two hours
because to get to that point was months
of my time just getting the data sets in
the right shape so that it can be
matched up with all the right
identifiers so I had just released this
week a package called maven which is
aiming to bundle all of the work that
I've been doing over the last couple
years into an easily in sort of a Python
package that does all of the data access
retrieval processing cleaning on device
so as to not shred a name chose around
licensing issues and also so you can see
what transformations I've applied and
change if you think they're not good and
say we also have some people
contributing back to maven doing their
first-ever pull requests and also
getting involved so if you want to see
what that looks like it's literally
there are identifies for every dataset
we've ever scraped and process and you
just do a dot get throwing the
identifiers and it gives you both the
raw and the process data side-by-side in
your local repo so this is available on
PI P I just do Pittman store maven or
come talk to me later if you want
otherwise thank you very much this is a
very very hard field to work in but very
challenging and rewarding thank you my
name is Jason and I want to tell you
about a project I did at University and
I used Python widgets and I want to tell
you a little bit about those and also a
little bit about having fun with your
model and playing with it a little bit
and making it into a little bit of a
game so the context is
this University project for my
visualization course the dataset was
using the vast challenge dataset from
2018 I think I don't have any once
worked with that before it's a
visualization community and what they
have is a series of challenges but the
one I looked at was we've got just over
2000 labeled bird tweets okay they're
labeled into I think it was 19 different
bird species and what you're given is a
test sample you're given 15 audio
samples that you have to classify so
this looks like to you to me a classic
machine learning exercise right and a
lot of people who entered the
competition they did the same thing okay
so I was got I got very excited by this
I thought oh great I'm gonna have some
fun with this I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
deep deep learning I'm gonna really
enjoy the visualization side I'm gonna
build this amazing front end for my
professor to see because I can't just
give her code she's not interested in
that she this is a visualization task
right I looked at what everyone else did
and what they did was amazing I don't
know how long they took but I had a hard
deadline I had what a few weeks to do
this and best laid plans of mice and men
it all kind of fell apart and what I
ended up doing I wanted to build this
this beautiful this aim here this you
know determine the likelihood of each of
the clips the classification model
visualize what ended up stripping it
back to was I produced I did a lot of
exploratory data analysis and notebook I
produced loads of nice visualizations
there and I ended up taking that
notebook and making that into the final
product so where I was gonna hopefully
use something like plot neo - ended up
using the the notebook and that was a
really good and very quick way to do it
and what I did was I took the notebook
and I just stuck a few I'd buy some
widgets in there and that was very
useful to me so if we've got time or
just try and have a look at that with
you so up here so we've got I feel like
I'm gonna like a link showing you my
naked body here but this is the the
actual script so
I never actually prepared this for
anyone to actually look at is including
my professor but of course as you've
seen a few things today yeah we can hide
all that so there's a notebook that was
what I was working with I tidied it up a
little bit but at the end of the day
we're just left with this and I think
you'll be able to hear these but here we
can start listening to some of the clips
here we have some spectrograms too to
understand the audio the bird sound
visually what's here is a what's called
a Rose crested blue Pipit and this is
what it looks like as a spectrogram this
is what it looks like we also have the
location of where all the samples where
all those audio clips were taken and
this is what it looks like in the Nature
Reserve this is the location of where
that audio sample was taken and the blue
is other samples of Rose crested lupa
bits and what we can do here with the
user is we can actually train the user
on how to how to distinguish a pithy
song a pivot call and then something
which is not a pivot and I wish I could
play these for you now and it would be
interesting to see the human learning
side of machine learning and then at the
end we can load a random sample of those
2000 and what it will do is load up the
visualization the audio clip and the
location so this could be and what
what's missing here this is where my
machine loud machine learning model was
going to give its predictions so I
wanted this to be kind of like an
Augmented approach so we've got some
classic visualization plus our machine
learning so we get to see all the
information and then at the end here
this is what I mean by you can play a
game with your machine learning model
we've got the classifications is this a
pivot or not pivot now I've done this a
few times I actually I think it's not
pivot look at the location look at this
this is what a pivot song looks like
this is what a pivot call looks like so
I don't think that looks like any of
them so I'd say not pivot and you know
correct
it was some other kind of bird and then
I can basically just go through this
loop again and what I did is why I
gave this to a test sample of people and
I asked them to work through this to
learn and they will learn how to
classify and then I could leave them
with this and they could try and
classify some so look this one this one
looks very much like the pivot that
pattern I know you can't see it very
well but this pattern looks very
familiar and look at the location so I'm
going to say that's a pivot yeah look no
surprise I'm getting this right every
time but I've classified probably about
50 of these things now but the
interesting thing is for me I did this
with human people
and although the classifier which I did
eventually get working after the
deadline worked with 2,000 samples it
turns out that humans can do this do
this job listening to about 10 samples
and they'll be loi about like 85%
accurate so don't give up on the humans
yet okay thank you
[Applause]
you